you are described as a man who's helped
save thousands of lives do you accept
that mantle that's quite a lot of credit
for one person and I think two things in
response to that is that this movement
the prep movement has been a very small
dedicated group of people and it comes
after decades of work by some very
passionate and committed people in a
time when we had no hope so I sort of
came in at the 11th hour and I work as
part of a wider group and and also
pre-exposure prophylaxis is it
preventive a preventative tool so it's
it's really treatment for HIV that saves
lives okay Jose what happened tell us
your backstory oh gosh and well I had
been looking online and seeing prep it
was made available in the United States
from June 2012 and I kind of didn't
think it was a thing I was like if there
was a pill that could stop you getting
hich IV we would all know about it and
we would all have it and so it took me a
couple of years into 2015 to decide I
was I was going to start taking prep and
at that time the summer of 2015 the only
way to get access to the medication was
to go and get post-exposure prophylaxis
because they give you that drug for free
and one of the drugs in that combination
is the drug we used for prep so that was
a little bit unethical because you have
to lie and it's wasteful and the only
other option was to get drugs from a
person living with HIV who didn't need
those drugs anymore maybe that had
changed meds and that's actually what
happened to me one of my good friends
had seen that I posted on Facebook that
I was gonna start taking prep and
offered me some some of the drug to take
that he didn't need so how did you
become aware of the challenges for
people who needed or wanted prep and
couldn't get hold of it and well I guess
when we're talking about those people
were talking about people like me so
there was no information and there was
no access and so I went I was going to
start taking prep but I went for HIV
test the next day after getting hold of
the drug and it came back hich every
positive so it was kind of a little like
when you find out that you're HIV
positive it's really weird it's in the
immediate moment like for me time Stood
Still and everything sort of slowed down
like you'd see in a movie everything
moved like it was in treacle and I went
out the front of the clinic to have a
cigarette and
and I just felt like I was the like in a
bubble not part of everyone walking past
and Soho it was just a very very yeah I
guess that shock but then a lot of
coyote happened for me and all the
things crystallized very quickly and I
decided I wanted to get on the front
foot with it and I went public about my
HIV status the very next day at a vent
called let's talk about gay sex and
drugs and then I posted it online
straight after that event and that went
a little bit viral and so people were
like I can't believe you've done that
about your HIV status and also what is
this prep stuff that would have kept you
negative so it was all a huge accident
and after 10 days of 10 people asking me
10 questions a day every day it was a
bit like I'm going through some stuff
and there's a problem if the main
inquiries of prep are coming to me for
someone who knew nothing so that was the
the the genesis of I want prep now so it
was built out of an accident and out of
necessity so what did you do tell us
what he did so and my cell phone our
co-founder Alex Craddock had been as
some activist meetings a few months
before and we'd heard that you could
import a generic drug for hepatitis C
cure for like a thousand pounds and the
treatment to cost the NHS 58 thousand
pounds or thirty-eight thousand pounds
so we were like well surely if you can
do that well it can work for prep and
actually have generic Truvada is one of
the drugs you can import legally three
months at a time for personal use so we
went to see a friend in the NHS who had
some anonymized data of people who'd
been doing this and having their blood
tested to make sure that it was real
drug and we were assured that it was
real drug from a short list off of
providers and six or seven weeks later
we launched I won't prep now and it's
traffic where we say about 20,000 unique
visitors a month and it's had over a
million pageviews and coming up to half
a million unique visitors so we have a
listed preferred seller and all they
have to do is go through the purchase
process it costs about 60 pounds for
three months of generic prep and it can
still have it straight to their door
there is a problem there because I'm the
first to say that's not equitable and
not everyone has a fixed address and not
everyone can afford a disposable income
of 60 pounds a month he wants people to
know that they're taking that drug if
you're married or if you're not out or
if you live with a family that's
religious you know
quite a lot of stigma around sex in
general gay sex and still HIV so it's
that's really one of the crucial reasons
why prep needs to be available routinely
on the NHS in England which it still
isn't where are we as far as that's
concerned
so Scotland have access for everyone on
the NHS and Wales have an uncapped pilot
and Northern Ireland have just started a
pilot as well but here in England they
announce the prep impact trial almost
one year ago this week I think and yep
so it was for 10,000 people they've
recently extended it to 13,000 but we
know for a fact and we have we have data
and anecdotes and case studies that men
who have sex with men gained by men are
being turned away from those clinics
because they're at capacity and some of
those men have contracted needlessly
contracted HIV now you won't remember
that cuz you're not old enough but you
we've got this advert that I remember
from the 1980s let's have a look at this
and this was yeah probably about 1985
anyone can get it man
so far it's been confined to small
groups but it's spreading
so protect yourself and read this
leaflet when it arrives
if you ignore AIDS it could be the death
of you so don't die of ignorance
thirty-six and being told by Steve my
producer it's not that sort of illness
anymore though is it's something that
you can live with rather than die from
and there is a lot of ignorance still
about the disease I mean I I live with
HIV I was diagnosed just over three
years ago and it's I took my pills once
a day and I pretty much forget about it
but I'm in a very privileged position
you know III there was no collateral
damage for me my family were supportive
and I didn't have a job or a strict
belong to a strict faith group that
would would penalize me for my sexuality
or my HIV status but the the the
condition itself is a manageable
long-term chronic condition and equal
life expectancy negative and positive
people but we've made huge advancements
in the medicine and treatment for people
living with HIV but we really haven't
made advances in what we all can do
which is trying to reduce stigma and and
make this something that people can talk
about and test for regularly we haven't
advanced on that very much at all and
they're ridiculous stigma I was chatting
to the chief of Stonewall quite recently
there's a risk
ridiculous stigma still about oh well
done promiscuity sick again what you
deserve I'm okay it's it pains me to say
it but I keep getting asked when when I
do things like this why prep is not
available and it's because it was
packaged and resisted as a gay man's
lifestyle drug but the more we do that
and more we paint that picture in the
narrative we're doing a huge disservice
to women who are vulnerable to HIV who
maybe wouldn't embrace the concept of
prep because of that so ironically
certain news outlets who are very thinly
veiled projecting homophobia are
actually doing women and other people
who are not gay men a huge disservice
while they continue to perpetuate that
what's the demographic of people with
HIV and oh I'm grasping for figures now
people living with HIV in the UK but to
give you a little bit of context as in
diagnosis because we often talk about
disproportionately affected but we never
put it into context so until very
recently because we've had some really
good news the last two years until very
recently half of all huge heavy
infections in the UK occurred in men who
have sex with men so gay and bisexual
men but we only account for 3 to 5
percent of the population so when you
take half
the diagnosis into about 5% that's when
we start to understand and
disproportionately affected but women I
think 30 percent of new diagnoses last
year were in women so it's something but
then you know we have to really highly
target it and I have a very specific and
clear message to get women to understand
their risk and to find a way to make
prep exam acceptable to them so there's
a lot of work to be done but I'm glad
that we're talking about it openly like
this now and women are infected because
they don't know their partner is
bisexual or gay there's well I mean it's
not just an illness that affects gay men
I mean as I said we're
disproportionately affected but there
could be a multitude of reasons why
women certain women would be vulnerable
to HIV sometimes it's just not
understanding your risk sometimes it's
not understanding how you contract HIV
and sometimes it's not it's not
understanding those other groups that
have a lot of hich IV prevalence there
so some sub-saharan African companies
some Eastern European companies and also
think you can only be accountable for
your own sexual behavior and you can
only really know that anybody else's
it's a kind of guessing game but it is
more highly targeted and nuanced work to
talk about prep and hich IV prevention
for women and we'd really like to see
some strong guts a vocal forward women
come forward and start to represent for
prep for women okay so what do you
suggest people do in order to keep
themselves healthy and safe because as
we were saying there's still that stigma
around people do not want to go and have
an HIV test I mean because they don't
want another result you tell you use
this right when it is we find out we had
some really really great news from
public health England and just a few
weeks ago and diagnosis of HIV in the UK
fell 17 percent last year and if we take
it in a two-year run it's actually
fallen by twenty eight percent but what
we're seeing is particularly black
African heterosexual men who have it
sometimes a phobia of the doctor or HIV
presenting very very ill so certain
demographics are not testing because of
the fear of finding out but it's always
better to know I mean I think I'm a
prime example that you can live
healthily and happily
with HIV but this stigma is a huge
barrier to stop people from testing and
we really need to start talking about it
more openly and we have national HIV
test week coming up soon so they'll be
all over Terence Higgins trusts and
social media which are here I work for
so people can find out where to test
locally and it's part of that initiative
through Terence against Russell and if
people want to know more about prep and
they want to become more active in
trying to make it available in England
what do they need to do they can visit I
one prep now doctor at UK and there's a
contact email address on there and then
they can send me an email through there
directly or they can contact Terrence
Higgins Trust directly we have a
Terrence Higgins Trust direct phone line
or an email address and that will come
through to me and and really get
educated find out what prep is and tell
somebody else until you know about it
now so tell somebody else when you go
home to your son or your girlfriends and
that's how we start to spread
information